this is blade of grass quite obviously
they came up with the title for its K
you know like somebody was just like you
know the first time I heard blade of
grass I thought like a real blade like a
sword that they're like let's make it
episode I meant that's that's my thought
cuz that's what I felt when I was a kid
I tried to slice people with grass it
didn't work except once actually no I
don't eat that when I was a kid
did you like grasses yeah yeah yeah
actually another uh what are you
actually used to do GI Joes you have
them fight grass no put Dilla grass in
their hand like it was a sword cuz GI
Joes didn't have swords except for like
two of them and weapon ninjas had and I
never had them yeah I wasn't cool enough
to have Snake Eyes or storm shadow yeah
well let's keep focus on the subject at
hand the very important serious subject
at hand Finn has a grass sword that's
actually kind of cool
um his hold sir what are they fighting
at the beginning I totally miss what
they were fighting I know did they ever
say what those were I don't think so
they were fighting on top of slides I
saw that been like these I don't know
what they were Michael Madsen there are
some things you're trying to climb up
and get them moms and Tom Sizemore
something like that yeah but his bottom
I his sword is not working very well
against the Michael Madsen zombies and
so he'd say you need a new sword so the
guys go to choose coos but then they
decide to go to someone else which at
first annoy me but he comes back since
okay and they go and he gives him this
this blade made of grass it's literally
a sword made out of grass and it seems
too perfect to be true it slices apples
too perfectly it cuts things up in
Finn's face and stuff like that but it's
getting a little too clingy literally it
will cling to his hand and not let go
and he tries to get rid of it but it
finds it way back so then I got the
truth scoots to tell him how to get rid
of it he tells him where the guy is he
goes they tried to defeat him they say
you can't get it off
your hand is stuck there for everything
okay actually it's kind of cool Emily
thinks it's cool it is cool and they
seem to live happily ever after or at
least by the others at the center so
yeah I guess he'd now has a grass sword
always on his hand um that's kind of
cool like it's a cool it I think it's a
cool invention I think the I know what
like this can't be the first thing to
have like a sword that's like a task to
you or like whatever comes out of your
insert it you know there's got to be
other snippet from I don't know that
this Wolverine Snicket oh no it's that's
what it is
no no it's it's Nick it but the sound is
posh because when the cartoon came out
it sounded so much better and they use
that sound the movies as well and
nobody's got built look Alice will
breathe no that's what sounds cool
right except for the fact that you have
like this never I'm not even gonna go
there
he really likes x-men to a fault well no
there's an example of a kind of yeah
exactly yes I it's not like you know the
first time is somebody's done that but I
like my Z and technically uh yeah it's
really good making a row yeah even
psylocke and stuff yeah but yeah I like
the idea of just like it's um from Soul
Calibur to what's-her-name IV like she
has a whip that's like a sword but then
it can also become like a whip - it's
like I love those things where it's like
it's like the most deadly thing and they
could just be like you know like just
like fabric or something happiness I I
wasn't gonna go there but I guess it had
to yes I gotta me another solid yeah one
minutes daily and next May is pathetic
yeah yeah that's just the way it is um
but yes so so I like his grass penis or
you know everyone always says I make to
make penis jokes but this time you force
me to go at director I was trying to be
a good boy but you focus me down that
road so yeah now we have his grass penis
sword and it's awesome I like grass
penis sword I like the grass sword I
think it's really neat therefore you
like the grass penis
no doesn't matter no penis at all no not
a blade of grass or a ninja sword
no never lame they just sort of be more
like a samurai sword I mean yes the
length isn't proper but it definitely
reminds me more of that
so when you said penis it remind you of
penis you were referring to like the
letter P the essence of the letter P so
P Ness is that the penis you were
talking about with that no I just wanted
to get you started talking on penis I
knew you just kind of keep going with it
so I had to start it I thought I was
billing Oh like it's it's a cute episode
it seems like an episode totally there
just to welcome this sword you know I
like the idea that it's always on his
wrist I'm sure by some episode they
don't come off or whatever but it's like
I just like the idea that's amazing I'm
the one that's the robot arm usually
right I'm just saying it's probably the
one that's usually gone right the right
yes yeah okay
this whole log is nothing but like sound
effects like the whole yeah next one
just could be like oh like oh that's a
v1 we need to get that it'll happen I'm
sure in the lapis suite so yeah I mean
it was one thing that was I don't know
if it's like if I thought was really
funny or it's like have a major
complaint is that true scoops was not
very animated at all but he's always so
animated that in this one when he just
like barely moves like yeah I think what
weighs like just goes go that way
and his arm will just go like this I
mean it was so not animated that I was
like it was kind of fun aqui that's
we're so used to seeing him you know so
energized and lively so I liked I think
the along with that actually Alma did
you notice there's one or two times
where the animation actually did seem a
touch choppy did you know is that no
nothing no okay there's more to like
when they're running you know usually
the motion is very fluent and stuff you
know and it's it's not a major complaint
because it's like with animated shows
especially growing up in the eighties we
saw a lot of bad yeah you know so it's
like not a major complaint but you have
a war one or two times where it looked
like just when they're running just a
little choppy like wonder do that for
anything else I'm gonna pop you though
maybe maybe I can't blame the show for
stuff like that with them not being
officially released yet so yeah good
point honestly even if it was like like
I said we grew up with cartoons of the
80s we're like half the new tutorials
masks were never right yeah re-watch
transformers oh my god and I love that
show my favorite show growing up but
terrible now it's yeah just a lot of
them like anyone that complains about
shows now is like that go go back to
some of them once we grew up with I mean
I like we still love them but they're
the pretty stupid terrible yeah I mean
we can we can come out and say that but
they're entertaining as hell but they're
pretty dumb no human said they're
entertaining as hell honestly rewatch
some of them they're not that
entertaining have you seen the he-man
she brought Christmas special yeah he
cried out have you seen attack of the
50-foot Emma yes exactly
okay well so yeah I'm yet I liked it I
thought it was fine what would you think
no I thought it was great I like a lot
of times he has a sword and everything
and it's just kind of there this one is
like a lot more interactive and I really
like that and I love anytime you like
cut stuff especially ways up against the
candle gang yeah candles and the guy
with the tattoo I love
was he someone like in real life that
has that cat that tattoo like even
without seeing the show and whenever he
cuts anything it's sin is the image and
all that stuff and I just love the sound
effect and it's very you know some
braces it's Asian in the sense of
samurai ninja stuff like that where he
moves and he's just like like it's a
journey it's very light very precise yes
very fluid motion it's not you know like
medieval times where it's like it's very
it's very skirt Snicket nah yeah I mean
it's not American okay fair enough
oh I love that I think it's really cool
like when he jumps over the guys his his
arm barely moves and and then all the
hair falls up I love that I think that's
just really freaking cool I like when he
first does the whatever the slice and
the tag whatever and is like it's so
precise that you even see the little
dots for the eyes fall out yeah like he
actually carved the little sake twine it
was so sharp that they fell out and
again it was just I love that thing
that's cool I love when he's going up
against all the gen crass monsters I
shouldn't say Giants all the grass
monsters and there's a big one and it's
coming down he just goes sorry and the
store goes into the fan yeah I love that
and that's cool it's it's one of the
most useful swords that he's ever had
and is this really cool why and what I
realized too that it's like I mean it's
been going on for out the whole show but
for whatever reason never really thought
about it is that you know the swords do
change and they all sort of have their
own identity mmm which I like and I
think there's something cool about the
fact it's very it's kind of comic-book
ish but in a good way that like you know
whatever I character can get a new
costume or something or whatever a new
power or something and it's like it'll
be with them for a while until and
they'll decide whether or not they want
to keep it or get do and I mean the
prank get a new one down the line
because that's part of just how it works
you know but but I kind of like that
where most shows again when we were
growing up with with show is it's like
their heads
this formula that wasn't just kid shows
it was sitcoms it was a dramas and stuff
like that where there had to be this
status quo they always had to come back
to its this formula and I know it's a
cool time now where it's like I mean
some show still have it but it's very
much
let's change it who says we can't change
it up yeah and movies are doing that now
too you know it's like with a lot of
these superheroes and stuff there's what
well you have to do this in the formula
you have to have them discovering this
you had to have this happen and it's
like particularly with the Marvel movies
it's like no you don't have to let's you
know Iron Man has to have a secret
identity end of the movies like I'm Iron
Man and just like throughout the rest of
movies everybody knows you know he's a
comic book though oh well then they'll
make you more like comics which is good
good parts of the comics so no I like
that I like yeah there's something cool
knowing it's like you know what they're
gonna have this new sword for a while
and I'm sure we get a new one later but
it's like it's like I want see what he
can do with this one now it's cool that
attached to him it's like you know I
don't know it's it's cool
anything else no I really actually I
loved a Salesman no returns
yeah no returns I don't think that's
that's it
I loved that no no I think it was a fun
little episode there's something I swear
I'm forgetting but it's gonna kill me in
the end
yeah whatever I like it